der mastwurf findet beim klettern in der
seilschaft zur selbstsicherung beim bau
von sicherungsanlagen und in der
bergrettung verwendung
es werden 2 gegen gleiche schlingen
gebildet und über kreuz gelegt
diese strenge können einzeln
belastet werden
einlegen
china
es wird wieder eine schlinge gebildet
kreuz gelegt
ein gedreht und eingehängt
das heil wird durch den anschlag
mit dem seil wird eine schlinge
hergestellt
dann nochmals selber
durch den einschlag punkt gefahren
das seil ende wird so herausgezogen dass
sich eine zweite schlange bildet
wird der mastwurf am seil ende gemacht
muss mit einem kreuz schlag begonnen
werden
das heil wir durch den einschlag punkt
geführt
mit dem seil wird eine schlinge
hergestellt und nochmals selber richtung
durch den einschlag punkt gefahren
das seil ende wird so herausgezogen dass
sich eine zweite schlange bildet
zum schluss
wird das durch den kopf
geführt und es wird ein zweiter schlag
um das ein laufendes heil gemacht